okay hello everyone
welcome to uh another episode of science
and technology q a for
kids and others and i see we have a
bunch of questions uh
stored up here um
let's see we have a question here from
frank uh what are the biggest
differences you notice about how
physicists think
versus how mathematicians think that's
sort of interesting and i
i think for people who are tackling or
experiencing mathematics at more of a
school level
experiencing physics at more of a school
level some of these things that i might
say
won't be obvious yet i'll talk more
about what professional mathematicians
versus professional physicists how they
kind of like to think about things
you know one of the features of physics
is
it's a field where people expect to just
figure things out
regardless of you know what methods are
going to be used what it takes
uh whether you're absolutely sure you're
right they just sort of bash through and
try and figure things out
mathematics is much more a field where
you're very careful
you say can i really prove this can i
really establish this am i absolutely
certain of this can i move on
i need to be absolutely certain before i
move on it's been an interesting thing
you know for people who study
mathematics study physics and so on
um at the level of people who go on and
get you know phds and things like that
there's a very impressive record of
people studying physics for their phds
maybe some very specific
area of physics and then going off and
kind of being exported to all sorts of
other fields
uh and uh and really uh kind of
transforming those other fields i mean
this happened in molecular biology
uh the people who were sort of the the
most of the early people in molecular
biology came from physics
it's happened in quantitative finance um
it's happened in a lot of different
areas you know you discover that
the people who uh do things oh well what
were they trained in they were trained
in physics
much more common to see that than to see
that they were trained at least at the
phd level
in mathematics mathematics tends to be
something where
you're more like i'm going to do these
things i'm going to get it absolutely
right it's going to be absolutely
perfect
but it's not like oh i can go apply my
thing to absolutely anything
you know one of the things i often find
interesting uh i have many friends who
are
top mathematicians and so on and uh one
of the things that's often
amusing to me is that i'll ask them some
question about some piece of mathematics
that
i kind of need to know about for
something i'm doing
and they'll think they'll think
and then they'll say i don't know
and the thing that i've discovered is
unless you hit
absolutely on target they're going to
say i don't know
because that's the right answer in a
sense they don't know
whereas if you ask that to somebody
who's more of a sort of physics-oriented
person
they'll say well i don't know that exact
thing but there's these other things
that are close by and
you know well there's maybe a bridge
from this to that and it's all a bit
more speculative it's not
sort of buttoned down precise but
it's it's more sort of uh uh
enterprising in a sense uh
intellectually
so that that's a little bit about some
uh difference
i would say that it can be the case that
physicists
use certain methods maybe mathematical
methods these days i hope computational
methods as well
and they get they say these are the
methods we're using
and they're methods that in some cases
are from mathematics that was developed
a hundred years ago or more
um and and they do what they can do with
those methods
mathematicians will also be
be based on particular methods so
particular sort of
methods of of constructing proofs for
things and
making conjectures and going on and
making proofs and so on
um the some of what they're doing is is
much more abstract than physicists
um sometimes uh it's um
i think mathematicians are are sometimes
very fond of sort of pure mathematics
which is sometimes defined as
mathematics that doesn't connect to
anything else
that's a bit unfair because it's turned
out that
a lot of mathematics that's been done
when mathematics is done
with good kind of aesthetics with good
kind of uh
thinking about uh you know what is the
essence of what we're doing and so on
it's turned out that the mathematics is
sort of almost inevitable applicable to
things
i remember meeting a a person many years
ago now a
person who worked on number theory um uh
who um was sort of saying well we were
very proud of the fact that uh
everything we did was absolutely
irrelevant to the world at large and it
was just
a question of doing these elaborate
things about equations involving numbers
and integers and
all these kinds of things and oh my gosh
then public key cryptography came along
and pretty soon all of these obscure
theorems that we had developed in number
theory
were incredibly relevant to computer
security and things like this
and it was i think this particular
individual was was a little bit pleased
that that had happened
but to some people it was almost a
shocking clash of cultures
to see the fact that these things that
have been developed
as a matter of pure mathematics turned
out to be relevant
um in the in the world at large and i
think sometimes um
uh you know if i were to to you you find
people with with just a great deal of
kind of intellectual horsepower
uh working in professional mathematics
um
sometimes they have a good feeling for
how the world really works
and sometimes they really don't and so
something that can happen
is they can say well i'm going to make a
model for how this thing in the real
world works
and i'm a mathematician i know in a sort
of an abstract way
how this happens and um uh but i'm
but but somehow the the notion of
of what it's going to take to do
something which has sort of the
practicalities of things in the world is
a bit lost
i'll tell one story this is perhaps more
of a historical story but but
um i think it's sort of a fun story the
person about a person named renee tom
who was the inventor of this field
called catastrophe theory
so catastrophe theory perhaps had the
misfortune of having a sort of trendy
name like that this was a
a field particularly popular in the
1970s um
the actual idea of catastrophe theory is
quite interesting
and uh and and not as sort of trendy as
its name suggests let me let me
just talk a little bit about catastrophe
theory and then i'll tell the story
so one of the questions is if you uh
if you try and um uh you have some
some beam or something you press on the
two ends well
for a while the beam will just sort of
it will maybe compress a little bit
um but if you press it if you press it
sufficiently hard eventually it'll
buckle
it'll either go up or go down it'll
buckle either buckle up or buckle
down so to speak um and that phenomenon
of this sort of bifurcation of whether
it sort of goes up or goes down
that's kind of an example of one of
these kind of uh a sort of a catastrophe
kind of thing
give you another example which seems
like it might not be related but
actually is
so if you look in your average coffee
cup i don't happen to be a coffee
drinker but i certainly
see coffee cups you look at an average
coffee cup
and you look at the the pattern made by
light
as it uh goes on the surface of of your
coffee or whatever else
okay you see a very strange thing you'll
see you might just see oh those big blow
of light but actually no it's not a blob
of light
it's a it's a strange pattern that has a
cusp
it has a sort of discontinuity it has it
kind of goes goes around like this
and has a place where it kind of has it
kind of discontinuously
uh makes this curve okay so that cusp
is another example of a catastrophe made
in a very different way
the way that's made is is the following
so
uh if you imagine light coming into your
coffee cup
the light hits the side of the coffee
cup and then it's reflected from the
side of the coffee cup
and winds up uh going on the surface of
your coffee
so the question is when you have a bunch
of parallel light rays coming from a
light that's far away like the sun for
example
what happens to those parallel light
rays when they're reflected off the side
of the coffee cup
well okay so this is now a matter of
mathematics
there's the one so one thing you might
think would happen oh there's
the coffee cup is kind of rounded so all
these rays of light will be concentrated
somewhere so it turns out a mathematical
fact is
that the only shape that perfectly
concentrates things as a parabola
or a paraboloid when it's when it's sort
of rotated around
so parabola is the shape that's made by
a quadratic
function like x squared for example and
it turns out
that's the shape that you need to make
things so that
if you have a bunch of parallel rays
when the rays are reflected
depending it doesn't matter whether the
ray is reflected from the middle of the
of the object or from the side of the
object it will always be concentrated at
the same
focal point and so this idea of
a parabolic reflector that's what's used
you know when you see radio dishes for
example
there'll be parabolic reflectors or
there'll be paraboloids
that are concentrating themselves uh
concentrating all these
all these rays that are the radio waves
that are coming in concentrating that a
point
so there's the highest intensity for the
detector which is going to pick them up
uh the same will be true with a solar
collector
if you have a collection of a mirror
that uh
the solar collector will have the same
feature that it's trying to
uh take all the sun's uh light that
falls on any part of the
of the of the collector and concentrate
it all at the focus where it might heat
something up or something like this
so these are the the kind of um
things that you see in um uh uses for
parabolas and paraboloids so for example
the hub
hubble space telescope um is uh
its mirror uh is a is a paraboloidal
mirror well it had some
issues and had to have various sort of
corrections put on but it's basically a
parabolical mirror
sometimes when people make paraboloid
mirrors they use a trick
which is that a parabola it's a
mathematical uh
figure and in modern times you can
imagine just sort of 3d printing
that paraboloid perfectly but in in all
the times one of the
one of the cool ways to make a
paraboloid is you take something like
mercury
liquid mercury and you spin it around
and it so happens that fluid dynamics
is such that the shape you get when you
spin a liquid around
is a paraboloid the surface of the of
the liquid becomes a paraboloid
and so one of the tricks for sort of
making uh
uh you could imagine making mirrors for
telescopes
that are going to con they're going to
focus light was to
spin mercury for example to make that
parabolic
but anyway so paraboloids focus
everything at a point
your average coffee cup is not a
paraboloid your average coffee cup is
circular and circular
circles um just or or cylindrical
um that doesn't focus things at a point
instead it focuses things
on this so-called core stick um that is
this uh this funny shape with a cusp in
it why is it called the caustic
caustic is because that comes from a
latin word i guess
which means to set things on fire and um
it's
just means means fire um the uh
and the point was that if you had a
bunch of mirrors and you were trying to
uh
you know attack the enemy from a
distance so to speak one way you could
do that
is to try and concentrate the sun and uh
try and
you know burn things and so on and so
that was uh
uh that's sort of the origin of this
term caustic but one of the places where
you see these
caustics is in um uh
is when when you have sort of parallel
light and
um you um you end up with a
knot and something like a coffee cup
that's circular it doesn't concentrate
things at a point it concentrates things
on a caustic
you also see those caustics for example
if you look at the bottom of a swimming
pool
you'll see those kinds of caustics
forming as a result of the light
being refracted through the surface of
the water
as the water has a little um ripples on
it and so on
so anyway one of the things that
one can study is this question of kind
of
when you have sort of the surface of
water and it's rippling around in
different ways
how robust is it that you have precisely
these same cusp like caustics and so on
and the answer is it's surprisingly
robust it doesn't matter
much what the detailed shape of the
water is
doesn't matter much what the detailed
shape of the coffee cup is you'll always
get the same kind of cusp like shape
and so that result is kind of a deep
result about
structural stability um that one could
think of as a sort of deep result about
geometry
it's a very deep pure mathematical
result that um
comes out of the uh sort of a a theory
of
of mathematical forms so a person who
developed this
uh back in the 60s i guess primarily was
was renee tom
and renee tom then wanted to take these
ideas and kind of generalize them to
different areas and uh for example he
tried to generalize into biology
uh he tried to use catastrophe theory
and this notion of sort of
continuous changes of uh of like
orientation of rays producing
discontinuous
uh kind of effects to explain things
like
uh why you would have a biological
organism where you know
one part of it would turn into a wing
and another part of it would turn into a
leg
so he wrote a book about uh biological
morphogenesis the creation of form and
biology and i was always a bit sad when
i saw this book because
this book was a required
kind of elaborate knowledge of biology
and elaborate knowledge of algebraic
topology
and various other areas of mathematics
and the set of people
with those kinds of elaborate uh domains
of knowledge was basically
zero there was basically nobody who who
knew
uh expertly both those fields and the
book kind of required those
but i'm i'm talking to you about uh sort
of ways of thinking of pure
mathematicians i remember meeting renee
tom once
um and uh he was uh
he was very very keen to discuss the
question of why the sky is blue
and it's like why are you talking about
this this is a fairly well understood
piece of physics to do with rayleigh
scattering
and properties of atoms and all this
kind of thing what does this have to do
with the pure mathematics of catastrophe
theory and so on
and he had some theory which i which i
never understood
but my strong suspicion about it was it
was a it was a theory that
that sort of didn't really connect there
was mathematics
that was very interesting and quite
robust and there was kind of
understanding of sort of the magnitudes
of things in physics
that was just way different from that
and um
so that was sort of an example of where
things can go wrong when sort of pure
pure mathematics is directly applied to
sort of modeling the natural world now
having said that
in our current fundamental theory of
physics that we've been working on
last couple of years with with great
success one of the things that's just
amazing is that a lot of areas of pure
mathematics that have been developed
over the course of
the last century or so that have not
really seemed like they're going to be
applicable to anything
are applicable to in our models a lot of
things to do with things like higher
category theory
and topos theory a lot of very elaborate
things where
when you read the mathematics papers
it's like why would anybody care about
this this is so elaborate
so abstract but it turns out there's a
really good reason to care because it's
probably how a universe is made
so that's kind of a really neat neat
thing there and it's sort of interesting
to see over the years
mathematics gets developed and their
mathematics gets used
and there's usually a delay between the
mathematics being developed and
mathematics being used
but it's interesting to see what
mathematics has actually been used so
for example
the mathematics one you learned in in
sort of elementary education arithmetic
things like that
that was all pretty well codified by the
1600s
um and the methods that people use to do
addition sums and so on with all those
carriers and all that kind of stuff a
long multiplication long division
i never really learned long division
myself um it's
uh but those all those various methods
um they were uh they were developed
by the 1600s 1700s and you'll find i
have copies of a bunch of old books
that um were people who were sort of uh
who made a living teaching merchants how
to do arithmetic
and they would all have their secret
methods for doing this is the way you
can do the
you know casting out nines and the rule
of z's and the
the rule of threes and all this kind of
all this kind of stuff
all these kind of uh cool sort of trick
methods for doing various kinds of
computations
which was an important thing because
obviously there weren't computers in
those days and if you were a merchant
and you wanted to you know charge 12
percent interest on something
it was really uh you had to actually be
able to do the computations necessary
but you know other areas of mathematics
like calculus for example
it got pretty well developed in the
1700s and um
that's sort of another area that one
learns today in sort of math education
there are other areas that um pretty
much all of the discrete mathematics
that we do today
is much more recent people always
thought discrete mathematics was kind of
trivial
it's actually much harder than
continuous mathematics in the end
but it didn't really develop until uh
until well into the 20th century
as a serious field people had worked on
it earlier than that but it didn't
really develop in the way that it has
but it's always been interesting to me
that there are some fields of
mathematics
where they developed they got quite
advanced
and they've never had a use found for
them so there's an area of trans-finite
numbers
i think i've talked about that a bit
before here um that was developed in the
late 1800s
which is still waiting for a real use
although it may be getting closer now
but um and i would say that you know
much of the time
mathematics gets developed and then
it gets used in physics some amount of
time later that amount of time maybe
decades
it may be half a century it may be a
century i don't think there are too many
examples of it being much longer than
that
the other thing that happens is that the
mathematics isn't available
and so the physicists just go and say
you know i don't care that the
mathematics isn't available i'm going to
invent
my own sort of uh perhaps very uh
sort of un robust version of the
mathematics to do the physics that i
want to do
so uh my longtime
friend dick fineman who is a well-known
physicist invented this method for
studying quantum mechanics called the
path integral
and uh mathematicians are still trying
to discuss what on earth does the path
integral really mean
for physicists it's like okay yeah we
can work things out we can do
calculations
oh there's some limit we have to take we
don't really know if that limit is going
to work at a mathematical level
but you know it's it's probably going to
work and in actual physics
it's a limit over this number of orders
of magnitude and it's probably going to
be good enough
and that's kind of the approach of
physicists sometimes they have to make
their own mathematics
and uh what's happened actually
particularly the last few decades
is mathematics that's kind of been made
by physicists
has them been fed back into this kind of
process of being made more precise
that mathematics is really good at and i
know from our physics project we have
spun off
a really very rich collection of
mathematics that
i think some mathematicians already
starting to try and
try and nail down i mean i think the the
nailing down process will take a long
time
and uh be involved a lot of very
interesting and difficult abstract
things
all right that was a long answer to that
um
well let's see there's a question here
from william a typical text file is a
few kilobytes a typical audio file a few
megabytes
a video file a few gigabytes uh what
would be a typical
file size for smell taste touch
is there a reason why quantitative
change leads to qualitative change
well okay so first question is uh what
leads to those differences in the
amounts of data
necessary to represent for example
sounds and images
you have to realize that what we're
trying to represent is a sound good
enough that when we hear it
it sounds right for an image an image
that's good enough that when we see it
it looks right
and so a lot of that question about how
much data there needs to be
in that sound or that image depends on
how we perceive sounds and images
and so that kind of gets us to look at
what happens in our brains
and in our eyes there's the nerve the
optic nerve that goes from
from the retina on the back of our eye
to rather
poorly engineered to the back of our
brain to the visual cortex
has to go all the way through the brain
um to get there the optic nerve
carries all the information maybe
i don't know um maybe 20 times a second
roughly
there's sort of new data going through
the optic nerve saying this is the image
i'm seeing
and uh so the optic nerve has a have a
certain number of fibers in it
and that those represent essentially the
pixels
in the image that we see on our retina
our retina has a bunch of
photo of light sensitive cells and uh
those light
sensitive cells are are connected to
fibers in the optic nerve
and the basic bottom line is that
they're about 10 million fibers i think
in the optic nerve
um they're actually a smaller number of
of of front-line
cells on the retina um but they're a
bunch of cross-connections that help us
to sort of
uh make improve our vision actually very
much like the way that modern cell phone
cameras
improve their vision um by doing various
kinds of local image processing
even in the in in the camera so to speak
anyway so
so for us there are about 10 million
fibers in the optic nerve
um and that kind of gives us a sense of
scale
of how much data we're we're going to
end up with um
for um uh the um
uh for um uh well from our visual system
so in rough terms the reason that you
know the few megapixel image
is the one that seems right to us is
because we have a few mega
uh nerve fibers in our optic nerve
okay so what about sound well we have an
auditory nerve as well
that goes from our cochlea our inner ear
to the the the sound center auditory
center in our brain
um that nerve has i don't know how many
fibers it has
maybe tens of thousands of fibers of
that order
it has vastly fewer fibers than the than
the optic nerve
and and that's sort of fundamentally why
we get less data from sound than we do
from from uh from from vision
um and what's happening there is in the
case of sound what we're doing is we're
sampling a sound at a certain frequency
so like the standard frequency is 44
kilohertz that's the frequency that uh
audio cds sample at and that's sort of a
typical sound frequency now
a cell phone well one of the original
things that
you know alexander graham bell kind of
innovated with
in developing the telephone was just how
low a data rate
can you go and have people still be able
to understand things
um uh they
um
they um
it's uh so the thing that
um uh so so
anyway in in things like even cell
phones
it's kind of shocking how low the data
rate actually is it's often eight
kilohertz
um and then there are all kinds of ways
that the
the underlying kind of um
uh data has been compressed and is sort
of expanded again
and it's kind of like you're just it's
sending through something which is kind
of like oh this vowel got said it
doesn't quite work that way
but roughly and then the the at the at
the
end where you're hearing it that's sort
of that oh it was the vowel a
got said and that turns into an ah sound
it doesn't quite work that way
it works in a more kind of mathematical
way rather than a way that has to do
with
the actual meaning of of the of the
sounds and so on
but any case so so with for us
by the time you get to 44 kilohertz
that's pretty much
perfect rendition of sound why is that
well it's because
our ears if you're young maybe you can
hear up to 25 kilohertz
uh somebody like me i'm down to about 20
kilohertz i think which is
actually pretty good for somebody as
ancient as me um
but uh maybe a little lower than that i
haven't tested it in a while
but usually as one gets older um it's uh
those hair cells in the in the um uh
inner ear get more sort of gummy
and one can't uh well they're not
sensitive to as high frequencies
this is a don't go to don't uh
don't expose yourself to too loud sounds
because
really loud sounds will destroy those
those hair
cells in your inner ear um which means
that you won't be able to hear higher
frequencies
which means it gets harder and harder to
actually be able to interpret
um uh sounds and so on so that's this is
this is one of those don't expose
yourself to very loud noises
messages um but any case back to the
question of sort of the amount of data
in these different cases so vision
because the optic nerve
it's megabytes uh
you know um sound because the auditory
nerve
it's kind of um uh well i should say
megabytes per image for vision when it
comes to a movie
it's you know gigabytes for a whole uh
you know hundreds of gigabytes for a
whole sort of decent
amount of video and so on and uh
megabytes for a decent amount of audio
so okay the question that was asked is
what about smell taste touch
and so on so to assess that we'd have to
ask how many nerves are there
that how many nerve fibers are there in
our olfactory nerves
um and how many how many nerve fibers
are there that come from all of our
touch
sensors and so on on all the different
parts of our body
um and i don't know the answer to all of
those
i certainly do know that it's
drastically variable
between different species so for example
we have pretty crummy
olfactory smell based
data collection whereas
animals like dogs for example have
really
good olfactory detection so i don't know
the answer to how much
data for for us humans i suspect
that we could get away with with a
remarkably small amount of data
to represent um things like smell and um
and taste now in practice you know a
typical
perfume or something that's a
manufactured scent has hundreds of
different chemicals in it
and exactly what effect from those
chemicals is important in the way we
smell them
i don't think anybody really knows it
probably has something to do with shapes
of molecules maybe vibrational states
and molecules
it all has to do with the way molecules
get attached to different sensors in our
noses and so on
um that are sensitive to different parts
or components of that chemical
smell but um the question of exactly
what parts of the smell
we're really picking up and really
paying attention to i don't think that
is
that's really known um and i think you
know the dimensions of smell we don't
really know
just like for color we know red green
blue are the kind of primary colors we
don't really know what the primary
smells are
for taste there's a little bit more
analysis of what the primary tastes are
and there are small number of them but
you know when it comes to taste
it's even more complicated because the
taste buds on our tongues
they actually depend on you know when
you taste something it's because pieces
of food are actually
uh chemically reacting in a sense with
the with
or being sort of chemically sensed by
the things in those taste buds
and it really matters in what what the
food is like did you mash it up
and did it get little pieces of stuff
little little particles
in your taste bud is it liquid you know
what's it really like
those things are important to the
perception of taste by taste buds and so
i don't really know
what the uh sort of what the dimension
for that would be
now you know people at various times
have um
in the effort to sort of make uh sort of
movie-like experiences as realistic as
possible
i remember from my probably 1950s
there were this technology i think was
called smell-o-rama
which was kind of a um a thing where i
think maybe it was even applied to
television sets
um where you would get you know there'll
be some event going on
and um there's some some video being
shown
and then at the appropriate moment some
some scent will be released
and you would get also this sense of
smell as well as a sense of of sight and
i know that
in like you know disney rides and so on
i think they they use those kinds of
things they they have they've actually
worked on you know making a
a certain smell to go along with the the
visuals and the sounds of a particular
ride
um and you know one of the things that's
that's complicated about something like
smell
is that the you know when we remember
things
there are things where people say well i
remember the you know
you smell something and suddenly you're
being reminded of something
and you didn't even know why you were
being reminded of it and it's because
that smell matched up it's like that
looks like blah blah blah
but actually that's that smells like
blah blah but
one of the things for us is that for
example our human language is not
well adapted to talking about smells
and so on it's it's some we don't have a
huge vocabulary for talking about that
um you know vastly less than the
vocabulary we have for talking about
visual
uh objects and so on so
that's uh um and i think
when it comes to touch one of the things
i've been
curious about is is whether there's kind
of a a um
uh you know they're textures and you can
say that's a rough texture that's kind
of a furry thing that's kind of a
a a a smooth thing and so on
but there's sort of a dictionary of
possible textures
and we still don't really quite know
what that is i mean there's some recent
work that's becoming making it a bit
clearer um what the sort of
spectrum of possible textures actually
is and
that's something that's kind of relevant
because on some uh
mobile devices there's starting to be
this kind of electrical effect
that can make your finger feel as if
there's something on the surface of your
phone
there's actually nothing there it's a
purely electrical phenomenon that's
stimulating
uh the the uh your finger um as a
uh just directly and electrically um
but it feels to you as if there's
something on the surface of the phone
and that can be useful as a sort of a
virtual button on the phone or something
and one can wonder you know can one make
something where there's kind of a
virtual version
of some particular texture and as as uh
you know
things change in a user interface or
something you feel a different texture
and so on
and that's some uh that's something
that's sort of probably a coming
attraction
i don't think we know uh what the um uh
how much data is going to be involved in
that my guess is a rather small amount
of data for us
but you know different organisms have
very different sensory systems even
even humans who who uh you know who are
vision impaired in one way or another
will have more sensitivity to different
sounds more touch sensitivity and so
on and and quite possibly there's sort
of rerouting
of uh of brain channels where you know
somebody who has you know got standard
vision like like me
um you know would be using all of that
brain capacity
to deal with all the data that's coming
in from my visual field
but somebody who's uh where they
they don't have vision um can uh
can use that sort of that brain capacity
to deal with sound or with
with uh with touch for you know that
that's a
um and that that's sort of a uh
a different direction i'm not sure how
well understood it is how those
different brain areas
um get sort of entrained to be used for
different purposes i know a few examples
of where uh you know brain areas will
get bigger and smaller
um in terms of of uh how
how much of one's brain gets used for
some particular kind of function
um depending on how much uh how how
often one is exposed to that kind of
modality
well let's see
um
okay
um
wow okay there's a um
it's a question here um
see this is a nice good test of its uh
name is written out in greek so it's uh
thanosis um is asking
this is a yeah okay this is a slightly
peculiar question for this
collection that might get me into
something interesting the question is do
you think there's a market for
small rockets in europe well i'm not
sure about that but maybe we can talk a
little bit about
space and space exploration and um
and so on one of the things that i think
is a
really interesting question in the
current time is
what's the good of putting things in
space you know since 1957
we've had the capability to put things
in orbit around the earth
so what what what's that good for
and i think that the um uh we're going
to see in the next few years
some answers starting to emerge to that
question
so for example in uh there was sort of a
comparable question about flight
you know first of all people had hot air
balloons and so on and then they had
uh you know uh powered flight airplanes
things like that
uh we've had those for 120 years um it's
like what are airplanes going to be good
for and at the beginning people were
kind of debating what our airplanes
gonna be good for and people said well
they'll be um uh the um uh they'll be
um kind of um uh you know maybe
airplanes will be good for carrying the
mail
maybe airplanes will be good for aerial
reconnaissance for photographing the
ground from a height and
seeing further uh maybe airplanes will
be good
well probably they won't be good for
taking carrying passengers around
that seems really hard and then later it
was
as the first world war kind of rolled in
maybe they'll be good for dropping bombs
on people
or things um so these sort of different
uses for
airplanes that emerged well it wasn't
obvious to begin with what airplanes
would be good for
actually the same thing for computers
when computers were first
invented as a theoretical matter in the
1930s nobody knew what they were going
to be good for and the fact that they
ended up being good for
storing data doing word processing doing
communications
networking all these kinds of things
those were completely unanticipated uses
of computers
um in the early days so when it comes to
things in space
there have been some expectation that
you could make communication satellites
uh what's the point of a communication
satellite well
basically if you're trying to
communicate from here to there on the
earth
one way you can do that is have a a wire
or a piece of fiber optic cable
that's laid under the ocean or whatever
else that goes from here to there
another thing you can do is send a
signal to a satellite
have it kind of bounce off the satellite
and come back to earth in another place
so i think back in probably 1960 maybe
even before 1960
the very first such such device was a
thing called i think was called echo1
and it was a very big mylar balloon so
those same kind of mylar balloons that
one has a you know birthday parties and
so on
this was a very big mylar balloon and it
was sent into space obviously it wasn't
inflated
it was only inflated once it was in
space and it was used to bounce radio
signals off
and it was a um and that was um that was
sort of the
the first example of being able to use
something in orbit around the earth
to communicate radio signals now things
have gotten a lot more advanced since
then
and um there's a lot um and
one of the so so both communication and
broadcasting so another thing that
happened more recently
was uh the idea particularly of of
satellites that are in geostationary
orbit
around the equator of the earth um they
uh
you know 24 000 miles above the equator
roughly the
the period of orbit around the earth
agrees with the period of the day
so that means that the satellite that's
in orbit um
around the equator uh because the earth
is spinning
uh so that it has to be on on the
equator
when when the satellite is in orbit uh
around the equator
at an altitude of roughly 24 000 miles
um it its orbital period agrees with the
the
one uh one day and so it all stays over
the same point on the earth's surface so
there are
geostationary satellites that are at the
longitude of the us
there are ones at the longitude of
europe and so on all
uh above the equator so for example when
you set up a
satellite tv dish you'll orient it so
that it is pointing
at that satellite so you know you always
point it to the south partly to the
south if you're in the
northern hemisphere so that it is
pointing at a thing that's over the
equator
um and uh that's how that works but
so for broadcasting things if you want
to kind of broadcast
some uh interesting television or or
radio or something to the us
you can do that from a satellite in
georgia stationary orbit
uh above the um above the u.s now
if you want to use it for cell phone
communications um it's too far
24 000 miles a long way and the signal
when you say hello
it's going to take uh let's see we can
probably work it out
um well let's see light travels 186 000
miles per second
so that means 24 000 miles it's 24 000
miles
up well actually it's more than that
because that's the distance that
uh the satellite is right above the
equator if you work out your kind of
trigonometry and
and pythagoras theorem and so on you'll
realize that the distance
uh to where you are on the earth is
longer than that straight
up distance from the equator unless
you're on the equator so let's give it
um let's say it's i don't know
40 000 miles up so that means that the
round trip
if you send a message up to the
satellite comes back down again that's
that's 80 000 miles so that means if
light goes 186 000 miles per second
that means you're looking at um a more
than a third of a second delay
uh you know you say hello and you know
to get
a response back is going to take more
than a third of a second that's the
latency of the signal um is going to be
that kind of time
uh for you to for you to kind of get get
the response back
actually it's uh it's ultimately worse
than that
i only think about that why that is
uh but in any case the the problem is
satellites that far away
kind of takes a long time to get the
signal back there and if you're just
broadcasting
you're never going to know whether you
saw that you know
amazing uh you know football event or
something
now or one second late doesn't really
make any difference
um so it doesn't matter when you're
broadcasting but it does matter if
you're doing
you know uh two-way communication so the
thing that was sort of the the
innovation
of uh the loud that is low-earth orbit
satellites and it's a much more
elaborate story there
um to you know you hand it off if you
have a satellite phone for example
you hear this little these days at least
i think that may be changing
with new technology but in the satellite
phones that have existed for the last
uh decade and a half or more you hear
this little
as the as it hands off from one
satellite to another
as one satellite uh is no longer in view
from where you are on the earth
another satellite comes into view but
any case that that's some
um uh so so one of the things is
is for sort of two-way communication uh
sometimes you know if you're using if
you're browsing the web
it also uh sometimes it's gonna matter
what the time for two-way communication
is sometimes if you're streaming a movie
it doesn't really matter if there's a
delay starting well okay
well and good but once it's streaming
all that matters is the throughput
not the latency of how long it takes to
go back and forth and so on
so uh in any case the the um
uh there's sort of this question of what
can you do with space
how can you make use of of things in
space
and for example it isn't yet possible
uh the the sort of power budget for
handheld phones
is not really good enough to
systematically have them
used to um to communicate with low earth
orbit
still a sat phone is still a fairly big
thing with a big antenna and things like
that
um really sort of small things don't
have an easy time
with current battery technology
communicating and rather
more actually antenna technology
communicating with things in earth orbit
so you end up having
uh you know little at least little and
you know antennas that you have to be
able to attach somewhere
to be able to do communication with low
earth orbit satellites well
but that's something as people look to
build out internet capabilities
uh to to more areas that's something
that uh
several friends of mine have companies
that um uh are
launching large numbers of satellites to
um
um uh to be able to to make use of that
uh that possibility but so that's
another sort of use of space another use
of space
is for uh kind of uh
doing aerial reconnaissance remote
sensing
being able to see the earth uh uh
frequently and now there's uh at least
one company the two companies actually
that have um
uh coverage of the earth that's good
enough you can get pretty high
resolution imagery
once a day and so the question now is
what's that good for
who needs to know what the earth looks
like what every place on the earth looks
like once a day
and oh by the way some parts of the
earth are cloudy and then there's more
technology
you have to have to see in the infrared
to be able to get through that or
or whatever if you can um but you know
it's like what's this good for
and that's a that's sort of a very
interesting thing to try to predict
you know what is space going to be good
for people back earlier on were talking
about doing manufacturing in space
being able to use the weightlessness of
space to be able to grow more perfect
crystals to be able to
make crystallized drug molecules all
kinds of things like this
that i don't think is really panned out
yet but again it's it's a complicated
issue because
as the cost of of putting something in
space
goes down if it can go down sufficiently
far
then new things become possible that
weren't even worth thinking about before
i mean all the kinds of things we're
doing to do with streaming video and so
on
back in the day that was completely
unthinkable because the
the cost of putting down copper phone
line
type communication technology was so
high that if you wanted to have
um enough sort of copper wire with the
communications technology of the time
to transmit video that was a hugely
expensive thing nobody would just do it
for fun so to speak but once it becomes
cheap enough you can do it kind of for
fun
and of course that leads to things like
space tourism and so on
and then but then there's another
parameter which is you know what's the
probability
what how safe is it you know if you're
launching 10 000 communication
satellites
and one rocket and 50 blows up which is
kind of a has been unfortunately the um
the typical statistic back in the past
at least i haven't checked it recently
um you know one rocket and 50 blows up
and it's launching tens of thousands of
communication satellites
well every so often you lose some
communication satellites and that's
unfortunate but it's not you know it's
kind of a cost of doing business
but that doesn't work well if uh if
you're launching people
um on those rockets and so on um and you
have to start thinking about you know
escape systems and
and all kinds of elaborate things like
that but it's also uh
even even if that's the case the kind of
um it's not a
it's not a good ride if you if your
rocket is launching and it blows up and
you have to be
sort of brought back to earth in some
kind of escape pod it's kind of not some
uh it's sort of poor customer
satisfaction i think in a case like that
um but you know there are there are lots
of other kinds of uses of space that
maybe we don't know yet and that's
that's one of the things that is
determining
i think the uh the sort of growth rate
of um of space-based
kinds of uh technologies um and uh
you know we don't know uh you know if we
could put things on the far side of the
moon for example
like people say radio astronomers say uh
oh my gosh you've got all these things
in orbit around the earth
and it's like um uh and that means that
when you do radio
uh radio astronomy which is looking for
radio emissions
from stars and galaxies and so on um
it's it's no good to be doing that if
there are all these cell phone
transmitters in orbit around the earth
because
you've got this this lovely radio
telescope on the surface of the earth
and it's trying to listen for some
distant galaxy
you know halfway across the universe and
and just right when something
interesting is happening with that
galaxy
a cell phone transmitter goes in its
path goes
in between it and that galaxy and and
all it's hearing is uh
is some uh encrypted piece of somebody's
telephone conversation
so that's kind of a bad thing i i
suspect the thing that's got to happen
in the end
is that the radio astronomers who are
all upset about um
about uh uh sort of um uh lots of low
earth orbit satellites
i think low earth orbit satellites are
useful enough they they're just going to
be lots of them
people are going to use them and they're
kind of the compensation is
okay people are going to use all those
low earth orbit satellites but
somebody's going to make the radio
astronomers
a radio telescope that can be put on the
far side of the moon
and if you have a radio telescope on the
far side of the moon at least right now
there's nothing it's really quiet there
because
the far side of the moon is all those
radio transmissions that are produced by
the earth
uh none of those uh are can be detected
on the far side of the moon
so it's really radio quiet on the far
side of the moon of course the question
is
how do you communicate the results of
your radio telescope to the astronomers
on earth
because i don't think they want
astronomers are often going to
at least used to often go to all these
slightly obscure places
because telescopes it's good to have a
telescope up in the mountains high up
above um sometimes above a lot of the
weather uh above all of the atmosphere
so you don't get sort of uh
little little glitches from um uh from
from the air um affecting you know the
twinkling of your star or whatever
being able to have the light come more
directly to your telescope so there are
lots of telescopes there's ones in mauna
kea and hawaii
there's ones in the uh chilean andes
um there's uh there's ones in different
places there's ones in arizona as well
but
but
um there's generally uh you know
telescopes on tall mountains
is a common thing and uh people um
astronomers
at least in the past my friends who are
astronomers it's like i'm off to this
place in the obscure place in the andes
um that's somewhat degraded in modern
times because
the uh there are fiber optic connections
to those telescopes
and they can just sit in the in the
comfort of their own home controlling
the telescope
um and uh there's no need to actually be
there for your observing night
um actually at the telescope but uh
uh you might think oh the astronomers
will have to go to the far side of the
moon but obviously that's not true
because um uh what will happen is
they'll be just like
there are there are satellites in orbit
around the earth that allow you to do
communications
you can have satellites in orbit around
the moon which can relay the signal from
a radio telescope on the far side of the
moon
uh to the earth and um of course
in time uh you know the the uh um
the the moon orbit might get us
congested as earth orbit
but i think that's going to be a long
while before that happens
um but uh you know those are those are
some of the things to to
to think about there i think one of the
things about launching rockets
is um it's um
uh the um uh you know the rotation of
the earth
is such that you want to launch a rocket
um to the
uh to the east because what you're
trying to do is you launch the rocket
and you're typically going to try to
make the rocket go into earth orbit
and let's see how does this work
uh you because of the uh centrifugal
force basically
hmm i have to think about this for a
second orbit insertion is easier i think
if you're launching
uh if you're launching
that way if you if you insert it into
the orbit going to the east
but that's why if you look at where
people have
satellite launch facilities most of them
have things to their east being
not much stuff so for example cape
canaveral
in the u.s is on the east
eastern coast of florida or near the
equator
because the equator the closer you are
to the equator the more angular momentum
you have which helps you in getting into
orbit so
bad idea to have a satellite launch
facility you know close to the north
pole better idea to have it close to the
equator
so in the us you know florida it's a
good bat
you want it on the eastern side because
you're going to have your rocket launch
up over the to the east and if something
goes wrong with your rocket
and uh you know it aborts somehow uh
it's it's or it blows up its debris is
going to fall
uh in the in the east um which is in the
atlantic ocean in that case rather than
falling
uh you know in some populated area and
so if you look i think um
in australia well sometimes there's some
places where there's a big enough desert
that you can
just you know launch uh in the center of
a continent i think in kazakhstan
the soviet launch facilities were
russian now launch facilities are in
kazakhstan
which is a a very big uh
fairly uh very sparsely populated
country
so that sort of works too um but uh
that's so in europe you're asking about
rockets in europe i don't think there's
a lot of places in europe
you know europe doesn't have a very
convenient eastern
uh kind of um um
seaboard and um uh there's not a lot of
places in europe where you get
to uh to launch a rocket and if it if it
fails
not have it for where people live so i
think that's some
uh which is why for example uh let's see
the
the french guiana is one place which is
used
for some european launches and there is
another place that i am forgetting
that's used that's close to the equator
um
that's that's used for some rocket
launchers
let's see questions as a question here
from d0 would those low earth orbit
satellites block out sunlight
not a chance just like you know all the
airplanes that fly every day
no real effect on the sunlight they have
a little bit of effect actually because
the the vapor trails they produce those
are like extra clouds and they do have
some effect
but the direct effect of the actual you
know
actual satellite actual plane it's so
tiny compared to the um
uh the the sort of what you see you know
i have to mention a
friend of mine has a a company that's
been involved in making
uh high altitude drones that fly at like
60 thousand feet
uh where the where the air is nice and
uh and smooth and so on
and uh it has a whole plan where a drone
can can have uh can get exposed to
enough sunlight
that it's possible to keep the drone
flying
for forever if the drone doesn't fail
the drone will just fly keep flying
forever
powered by sunlight um and uh in fact he
has a
uh this company has a has a whole scheme
for having whole fleets of drones
where just like birds where where you
have a flock of birds
and the birds are flying close in
formation
because they're using the wingtip
vortices from one bird to give lift to
another bird in the in the flock so to
speak
do the same thing with high altitude
drones and with modern control systems
you can have these things fly at high
speeds at 60 000 feet you know with
their wingtips one centimeter apart and
so on
so that they're effectively having a
giant wing area but
um one of the things that i find
interesting about that
uh is that when you do that well so
there's a lot of things that are
interesting about that that case but
but uh for example you can have a lot of
computation going on on those
on those drones um and um uh
that's um that's something that um
um the uh um
uh you you don't have any issues with
cooling
if you're at 60 000 feet so that that
allows you to kind of have
the joke is you can kind of have the
cloud in the cloud you know the
computing cloud
um that is uh so centralized computation
you potentially have it in the cloud so
to speak it's far above the clouds
um because you can actually have uh
computation
powered by sunlight and uh cooled by the
fact that you're at 60 000 feet
where it's much colder um and and do
computation there
but anyway why was i why was i telling
you this
because i i just have this image of um
these
uh high altitude drones um that usually
will be absolutely invisible because
they're
tiny on the on the scale of of the of
the size of the sky
but um uh kind of when they when they
need to be
you know they have to be have
maintenance done on them and things like
that and it's kind of the
amusing concept of the sort of once a
year or something
all these drones kind of uh you know
come in formation and decide that
they're going to come and land somewhere
and it's kind of like the like you would
see a flock of birds except these are
artificial objects that you know once a
year just in a migratory pattern so to
speak
um come and you know land and who knows
what you know colorado or something
something high altitude or whatever um
and uh to be to be serviced
um i am going to have to go quite soon
but um
let me just uh uh look at um
uh some other questions
here
well as uh so many interesting questions
um a few of these are more appropriate
for uh
history of science and technology um
uh let's see
okay so question from epi is a little
bit complicated maybe for this
um
[Music]
okay i'll just okay my last thing here
there's a question about using atomic
clocks
very accurate clocks that base their
timing
uh you know usually with a clock you
like a like an old-fashioned pendulum
clock you're just using
tick tock etc or you might be using
um some you know in a watch or something
a mechanical watch you're using
this kind of um it's again a little
pendulum like thing swinging back and
forth
you can do that in an atomic scale and
atoms have the convenient feature that
all atoms of a certain type
of a certain precise type are exactly
the same that's one of the things
that quantum mechanics will claim for us
and so
you don't have to say oh so i got some
dirt on my pendulum
or oh that pendulum wasn't manufactured
to exactly the same length
instead all atoms of cesium are exactly
cesium whatever it is are exactly the
same and so you can use that as a sort
of precise
it's not a pendulum but you use a sort
of vibration in that molecule
quantum mechanical vibration in that
molecule as a as a way to
to measure time well it turns out that
one of the consequences of general
relativity
einstein's theory of gravity is that
when you have a gravitational field um
in a gravitational field a clock will
run slightly slower
and so there's a phenomenon it's called
gravitational redshift
and um as you um
uh am i getting this the wrong way
around let me think
um
i have to think carefully about this it
runs at a different speed let's not
let's not say higher or lower because it
depends on what you mean exactly
by gravitational potential it gets a
little complicated so
in any case as you go in different so
for example on the surface of the earth
a clock will run to slightly different
speed than where there's the gravity
uh associated with being that close to
the earth will run at a different speed
than it would
if it was uh somewhere out in uh in
interplanetary space
and so the question is if you have a
whole arrangement of these atomic clocks
and you can very precisely measure times
can you use that to deduce the
gravitational field around you
and so for example on the earth you know
when you drop something it falls under
gravity roughly 9.8 meters per second
per second
but it isn't exactly 9.8 meters per
second per second everywhere
if you're near a mountain for example
there's usually a bit of extra gravity
associated with kind of the the mountain
and things will fall a little bit
towards the mountain
not just straight down towards the
center of the earth so
you can use those kinds of motions to
detect the the
kind of gravity but you could also in
principle
use timing variations and atomic clocks
to
to figure out gravity and and one of the
things that i'll just mention
people often say oh we're going to make
use quantum mechanics
to make sort of these perfect secrecy
systems where we're just going to use
quantum effects i don't really believe
this quite quite works that way
that's something comes out of our
physics project but one of the things
that's always
a problem even in in sort of pre-our
physics project physics
is gravity is still something that has
there's an effect from those sort of
quantum mechanical photons presumably
have a gravitational effect
so when people say i remember from years
ago visiting an early company
that claimed it could do sort of quantum
encryption and it's like they gave this
whole
story about how you know it's physically
proved that it's impossible to break
this encryption
say well excuse me what if you have
these very accurate atomic clocks or
some measurement of gravity
then can't you tell whether the photon
went this way or that way
and it's like well uh yes uh but we
don't know that piece of physics yet
so it's kind of it's the same story very
much as sort of mathematical
security it's like we know this because
we know this piece of mathematics
we don't know what we don't know the
mathematics we don't know
similarly we don't kind of know the
physics we don't know and um
i have to wrap up here for today um
and uh there's just a a great set of
questions here which i'll look forward
to
addressing continue to address some next
week
so um thanks for joining us
and uh bye bye for now